[Captions by Y Translator]
Today, we're going to be using
some 3D printing filament
for a slightly unusual use.
We're going to try
melting it down in a pot,
and casting it in silicone.
[Music]
You guys have wanted to see
quite a few different versions
of our Diamond Play Button cast
in different stuff.
So today, we're going to try
using 3D printing filament.
What are the supplies here
that we're using?
Well, we have a few
different rolls of filament
and provided by MatterHackers.
We've got these ones here,
which are glow-in-the-dark,
and we've got a few
of these over here
that are black,
and all of these,
instead of just being
a rigid plastic,
are kind of a rubbery plastic.
So we're hoping
that we'll end up with kind
of a rubbery glowing
gem Diamond Play Button.
Here's the basic idea.
We've got rolls and rolls of this
filament provided by MatterHackers,
and we're going to see
if we can melt it on the stove,
and then pour it into
our Diamond Play Button mold.
First, I think we need
to do a small-scale tests.
We've got our tiny little
Bite Club soap bar mold.
We'll try melting some
down on the stove,
and we'll see
if we can cast it here.
[Music]
So this is not the
correct way to melt
3D printing filament, right?
Right.
[Music]
Oh, that is not nearly as
runny as I thought it would be.
No, it's kind of goopy.
Wow.
Is it too hot to touch?
Yes.
I'm gonna touch it.
I failed.
I failed on everything.
I failed everything
I've ever done in life.
So attempt one,
we obviously did
not have enough,
and someone may have
accidentally touched it so it...
Who was that?
Lift it up.
Who did that?
Be quiet, Nate!
So we're going to go ahead
and pop this one out.
Yeah.
We're going to try
again with a lot more.
Go go go.
Oh that--
That is...
Has anyone ever seen
the villain of FernGully?
Smooth.
[Music]
This is mostly cooled down.
Well, partially cooled down.
The outside is
feeling pretty rigid.
But I want to get
it all the way cool
before we take it out
in case it deforms.
So I think we're just going
to use some cool water.
[Music]
Okay, better.
That's not too bad.
We obviously missed out
on a few of the details spots.
Now, this is not as liquid
as a lot of stuff
that we've done
with this mold, so...
That's very true.
This stuff going in is
pretty thick and gummy,
and the mold
that we're going to be using
for the Diamond Play Button
doesn't have the same
tiny inlaid details.
I think to try and make it melt
a little bit more evenly,
we're just going to take
a whole bunch of this,
and we're going to just
cut it into like
little one inch segments.
So it's not in that circle,
where some of its
being held up.
We're just going to try
and fill it with like
these little chopped up bits.
Good aim.
[Music]
We've got plenty
of our plastic melted here,
and I'm hoping we have enough
that we can just pour it
right into the diamond
triangle portion here,
and not have to worry
about like, oh,
there's some parts
that didn't pour out.
I don't want to have
to scrape it out.
I want to be able
to just pour it.
Much nicer.
That's getting melty.
It looks like hot cheese.
[Music]
Now, I don't know
what we're going to do
about the bubbles,
because there's quite
a few bubbles here.
[Music]
Yes, that.
Do that.
If nothing else, hopefully,
the bubbles will just rise
to the surface here,
and you won't see
them on the the top
of the Diamond Play itself.
[Music]
At this point,
all of our filament
has been melted down nicely,
and we're ready to start
pouring that in.
But before we do,
I think we're actually going
to take a little piece of paper towel,
and try and apply sort
of a print coat by almost
using these as a paintbrush.
Just coat the bottom of this.
I'm hoping that'll give
us a nice smooth layer,
and maybe a few less bubbles.
[Music]
This smells like really
badly burnt coffee.
Okay, we've got
that layer in there,
and that's already pretty much
cooling down quite a bit.
But we're just going to reheat
what's in the pan
for a minute just to make sure
it's all nice and even,
and we'll pour that in,
and that won't be
enough to fill this,
that should only be enough
for probably half of it,
and we've got another batch
that will do.
If Starbucks went on revolt,
this is what it
would smell like.
So you think maybe people
with 3D printing filament
should just put it
in a 3D printer?
[Music]
Don't do this
to your copper pans, kids.
[Music]
This is a 3D printer provided
to us by MatterHackers.
They're the ones
who also provided the filament
that we're using to make
our plastic play button,
and this is
a really cool machine.
And guess what?
We are actually giving
one of these away.
Now, this one is the Lulzbot,
and my favorite part
is probably the fact
that a lot of this
is actually 3D printed itself.
This piece was made by one
of these machines.
It's the coolest.
Like it does have metal parts,
but it has a lot of...
Like all the bright
green stuff, 3D printed.
You can see a lot
of this housing,
like you can see some
of the print lines 3D printed.
Just goes to show you
how well this works.
Normally, these machines
are about 2,500 bucks,
but you can win one for free.
To do so, you need
to be a subscriber,
and enter the contest using
the link in the description.
Grant has been playing around
with some 3D modeling software,
and you can see some
of the things he's already
printed off here.
We've got giant Lego piece.
We've got working gears.
We've got giant cookie cutter,
or for a sandwich,
if you want to turn your
sandwich into puzzle pieces.
A ninja star, a Transformer.
This is the the
little nickel shooter,
we made out of cards before.
This one's just
all 3D printed,
including the coins in it.
All right guys,
so we've already showed you
what happens when you melt
3D printing filament.
Now, we're actually going to
show you what it's really for.
[Music]
I think we're ready
to demold this thing.
We've now poured in...
I think we had to do
three layers just to get enough,
and it would like go
in all bubbly and full,
and then as it cooled down,
it would drop a little bit.
I would say this is probably
not the smartest way to do this.
We use what?
A spool and a half.
Probably.
Several pounds of filament.
>> Of filament.
Now, this is
actually fascinating.
It kind of does
what brownies do it.
It pulled away from the edges
of the silicone mold so...
A lot of things you can cast
with will shrink
a little bit as using.
This is no different.
Normally, this filament
isn't used this way,
and I think if you don't have
it full of air bubbles,
and just boiling
on a pan on the stove,
you're not really
going to run into this.
I've never seen anything
3D printed shrink,
but this method definitely
shrunk down a little bit.
But that should at least
make it easy to demold.
This is like
the easiest demolding
of anything I've ever demolded.
Ready?
Yeah.
That turned better
than I thought.
It turned out pretty nice.
It's so much...
It's actually...
So much 3D printing plastic.
That is...
That's a tough sucker.
Also, it's a lot lighter
than I thought it would be.
>> Really?
>> Yeah.
>> Oh wow.
I'm curious.
Let's weight this.
A lot of bubbles.
We're at 2.6 net.
So basically 2.7 pounds,
or 1,225 grams.
I do want to trim this off
ao the back is nicer.
I want to light it up.
By that you mean,
making it glow in the dark,
not like lighting
it on fire, right?
Dang it.
[Music]
Yeah.
That is a glowing
Diamond Play Button.
So something that I'm noticing
here is the glow does not last
nearly as long,
and is he's not nearly as bright
as the filament is normally.
I think that's true.
I think after being
cooked the way we did,
something has changed,
and it doesn't glow
quite as well.
Yeah.
>> It just so glow.
>> I think it's true.
So when I take this off,
it's glowing pretty bright-ish.
But it fades super fast.
Now, let's try
the actual filament itself.
Let's do like a side-by-side.
Okay, yeah, even
the color is different.
You can see that this
almost has a green glow,
and this one,
this yellow glow
is almost out.
Wildly different,
but it definitely--
I do think the filament
still has more glow.
Is that show--
No, that's...
Yeah, I think that's showing up
on camera pretty well.
Yeah.
I think the filament
charges faster,
and stays glowing little bit
longer, but it is still glowing,
and that's still neat.
Very cool.
What do you think we
should do with our 3D
print filament button?
It's not 3D printed,
but it is 3D printer filament.
Let's drop it off of something.
I wonder if it's
like bulletproof.
There are many things we
can maybe do with the slightly
rubbery 3D print filament
Diamond Play Button.
What do you guys
think we should do?
That's actually kind of funny.
It's like purple...
Green.
Once again, thanks to MatterHackers
for providing the filament.
Check the links
in description for the contest
where we are giving
away Lulzbot 3D printer.
It's worth 2,500 bucks.
It's so cool you guys.
Guys, that's it for today,
but the fun doesn't end.
We've always got more
for you to see.
That box up at the top will take
you directly to our last video,
you should go check that out.
The other box
is going to show you
what YouTube thinks you
should be watching next,
and this bomb the middle
will subscribe to the channel,
so you never miss
out on the fun.
Don't forget to ring that bell,
and we'll see you
in the next one.
Talk to you then.